Speaker 1: I also want to invite you to subscribe
free to The David Pakman Show sub Reddit with
now more than 30000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribe at David Pakman Dotcom.
Read it this morning.
I saw some interesting posts, including one
that asked, so do anti AXA's think that their
friends will still hang out with them?
One of the easiest steps you can take to reduce
covid risk is to not see anti vax people that
you might know.
Even though I am now vaccinated and fairly
comfortable returning to more normal activities,
I will definitely avoid anyone that is.
Antibalas, says this viewer do a.
maxus thing.
People won't avoid them.
We've been avoiding risky activities for a
year or so.
Do they think people will just start hanging
out with them again?
Maybe friends deciding not to see, give AXA's
will nudge them towards getting the vaccine?
I think there will be that to a degree.
I think it depends on what part of the country
you're in.
But I know that much to the chagrin of those
who are now suddenly want medical privacy,
I regularly am saying to people, are you vaccinated?
I was invited to something a couple of weeks
ago and I said, is everybody vaccinated?
And I was told, yes, everybody is.
And I said, great, OK, I'll be there.
And when I was invited to a different thing
three weeks ago and I was told, well, you
know, of the four couples, two are not vaccinated.
I said, yeah, it's not for me.
I'm just I'm not doing indoor stuff with unvaccinated
people right now.
It just doesn't it doesn't really make sense.
Even though I am vaccinated outdoor, I will
do.
I think that will be an issue.
And I think that's a really good thing in
if it influences more people into getting
vaccinated for sure.
Another user says the party of free speech
looks to cancel Liz Cheney for speaking against
Trump.
Yeah, this is I'm glad that this is is being
exposed.
The incredible double standard on cancelation
and free speech, the side that has been claiming
to be all about free speech and claiming to
be all about not canceling people is now trying
to cancel Liz Cheney.
They're trying to get her removed from her
leadership posts.
They're trying to get her off of committees.
They want her primaried and removed because
she had the audacity to think for herself
on impeachment and she had the audacity to
say what should be really uncontroversial,
which is, hey, Joe Biden won.
The election wasn't rigged.
And, of course, as much of this free speech
for us, but not for you, except it depends
unless you disagree.
But if we like it, then of course, we'll defend
it.
It's always been a pathetic hypocrisy, it
should be pointed out.
And the Liz Cheney cancelation attempts are
only the latest example.
And then lastly, a user claiming that Tucker
Carlson inspired assaults have started.
So I want to be clear that there has been
a horrible attack in New York City by an individual
who came up to another and said, take off
that mask and beat them.
And we have no particular reason to think
that the the attacker was inspired by Tucker
Carlson's recent rants, saying if you see
people outside wearing a mask, tell them,
take the mask off.
We have no reason to think that.
But the Tucker Carlson statements, the Tucker
Carlson rants about being against masks are
the type of thing that we often describe as
stochastic terrorism.
In this case, it's not terrorism.
It's stochastic A.I.M. ism or something like
that, where if you have a large enough audience,
some people will hear you say demand the masks
be taken off and they will do it and they
they will even take it to the next level.
They're certainly not going to be any liability
for Tucker Carlson.
I'm not suggesting that, nor am I suggesting
that there should be.
It really raises some very dangerous questions.
If just saying that then would be linked back
to Tucker and Tucker could get arrested because
someone told someone assaulted someone else
over a mask.
That's not what I'm suggesting.
But there is no question that given the size
of Tucker's audience, it will have an impact.
And whether this has any connection to Tucker
or not, we will never know.
But there are you know, with great power comes
great responsibility.
I don't know who said that that might have
been.
I don't know who said it.
It might be from Spider-Man, actually.
I don't know.
But there is a responsibility to understand
what would be the follow on effects from the
things that you say when you have a platform.
I try to think about that every day and it
certainly will have an impact.
Join the discussion on The David Pakman Show
sub Reddit David Pakman dot com slash Reddit,